right from the start software
development comprise
two different departments the
development team that develops the plan
designs and builds the system from
scratch and
the operation team for testing and
implementation of whatever is developed
the operations team gave the development
team feedback on any bugs that needed
fixing
and any rework required invariably the
development team
would be idle awaiting feedback from the
operations team
this undoubtedly extended timelines and
delayed the entire software development
cycle
there would be instances where the
development team moves on to the next
project
while the operations team continues to
provide feedback for the previous code
this meant weeks or even months for the
project to be closed
and final code to be developed now what
if the two departments
came together and worked in
collaboration with each other
what if the wall of confusion was broken
and this is called the devops approach
the devops symbol resembles an infinity
sign
suggesting that it is a continuous
process of improving efficiency
and constant activity the devops
approach makes companies adapt faster to
updates and development changes
the teams can now deliver quickly and
the deployments are more consistent and
smooth
though there may be communication
challenges devops manages a streamlined
flow between the teams
and makes the software development
process successful
the devops culture is implemented in
several phases with the help of several
tools
let's have a look at these phases the
first phase
is the planning phase where the
development team puts down a plan
keeping in mind the application
objectives that are to be delivered to
the customer
once the plan is made the coding begins
the development team
works on the same code and different
versions of the code are stored into a
repository
with the help of tools like get and
merged when required
this process is called version control
the code is then made executable with
tools like maven
and gradle in the build stage after the
code is successfully built
it is then tested for any bugs or errors
the most popular tool for automation
testing
is selenium once the code has passed
several manual and automated tests
we can say that it is ready for
deployment and is sent to the operations
team
the operations team now deploys the code
to the working environment
the most prominent tools used to
automate these phases are ansible
docker and kubernetes after the
deployment
the product is continuously monitored
and nagios is one of the top tools used
to automate this phase
the feedback received after this phase
is sent back to the planning phase
and this is what forms the core of the
devops life cycle
that is the integration phase jenkins is
the tool that sends the code for
building
and testing if the code passes the test
it is sent for deployment
and this is referred to as continuous
integration
there are many tech giants and
organizations that have opted for the
devops approach
for example amazon netflix walmart
facebook and adobe netflix introduced
its online streaming service in 2007.
in 2014 it was estimated that a downtime
for about an hour would cost netflix 200
000
however now netflix can cope with such
issues
they opted for devops in the most
fantastic way
netflix developed a tool called the
simeon army that continuously created
bugs in the environment
without affecting the users this chaos
motivated the developers to build a
system
that does not fall apart when any such
thing happens
so on this note here is a quiz for you
match the devops tool with the phase it
is used in
a
b
c
[Music]
d none of the above today
more and more companies lean towards
automation with the aim of reducing its
delivery time
and the gap between its development and
operations teams
to attain all of these there's just one
gateway
devops and if you're also looking
forward to doing the same
and excel in devops check out simply
learn's post-graduate program in devops
design and collaboration with caltech
ctme the program can help you master
several
in-demand devops skills and tools like
continuous integration and delivery
devops on cloud kubernetes docker and
much more
we hope you enjoyed this video if you
did a thumbs up would be really
appreciated
here's your reminder to subscribe to our
channel and to click on the bell icon
for more on the latest technologies and
trends thank you for watching
and stay tuned for more from simplylearn
you